kamala harris sénatrice de californie
à 55 ans c'est elle qui a été choisie
comme colistière pour affronter donald
trump à la présidentielle américaine de
novembre
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le candidat
démocrate joe biden ce mardi lors d'un
message à ses partisans
j'ai l'immense honneur d'annoncer que
j'ai choisi kamala harris combattant
dévoué à la défense courageuse des
classes populaires est l'une des plus
grandes serviteur de l'état comme ma
colistière une femme au parcours
exemplaire demande à des procureurs à
san francisco 2 fois procureur général
de californie
un choix célébré dans les villes où elle
a grandi et affûter ses armes politiques
voici une femme noire une femme d'asie
du sud-est puis de deux parents immigrés
mais à oakland en californie qui monte
sur scène d'une manière que nous n'avons
jamais vu auparavant dans l'histoire
c'est cela le rêve américain et je sais
qu'il y aura une nouvelle énergie pour
faire en sorte que ce ticket de by john
harris gagne ce que j'ai toujours
apprécié chez kamala c'est qu'elle est
dure mais elle est compatissante elle
est compréhensive et elle a toujours
essayé d'aller au fond des choses pour
s'assurer que les décisions qu'elle
prenait étaient les bonnes décisions en
fonction des personnes qui vont être
touchés par cette décision
une nouvelle accueillie avec beaucoup
d'honneur par l'intéressé unifier le vol
américain s'il allait assister à la vie
à se battre pour nous et en tant que
président il construira une amérique à
la hauteur de nos idéaux dans la course
à l'investiture la candidate avait battu
en retraite dès décembre pour rallier
joe biden au mois de mars une faible
performance pour donald trump qui n'a
pas manqué de railler s'invite à
l'adversaire elle a raconté beaucoup
d'histoires qui n'était pas vrai elle
est très forte pour augmenter les impôts
elle veut réduire les fonds pour notre
armée à un niveau que personne ne peut
même croire
en plus elle était très très méchante
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
cela m'a surpris elle était très
probablement plus méchante que même
pocar
pour joe biden elle a été très
irrespectueuse envers joe biden et il
est difficile de choisir quelqu'un qui
soit aussi respectueux elle a dit des
choses horribles sur ce lipide jo
pendant les débats des primaires
démocrates
un parcours exemplaire première femme à
diriger les services judiciaires de
l'état le plus peuplé du pays
première femme noire sénatrice dans
l'histoire américaine si elle reste une
pionnière quelques points pourrait lui
faire défaut
les interrogatoires musclés au sénat sur
un ton parfois glaçant un passé du
procureur jugeant durement des délits
mineurs notamment de la population
afro-américaine une indécision critiquée
dans son camp notamment sur sa position
sur le système de santé américain
mais la présidentielle dès 2024 dans le
viseur diront certains la ténacité de la
colistière est indéniable et ses chances
d'une victoire aux côtés de joe biden ne
semble pas utopique